one of the most pressing choices facing
modern economies is whether to adopt a
policy of free trade or of protectionism
that is whether to encourage foreign
goods into the country with minimum
tariffs and allow industries to relocate
abroad or whether to make it hard for
foreign firms to sell their goods
internally and discourage domestic
producers tempted by cheaper wages in
other lands it feels like a very modern
dilemma but the debates between
proponents of free trade and
protectionism go back a very long way
the argument began in earnest in Europe
in the 15th century with the formulation
of a theory known as McCann tel ISM the
forerunner of what we today refer to as
protectionism mecan't ilysm was like
nearly every other economic theory
interested in increasing a nation's
wealth but McCann tellest argued that in
order to grow richer a country had to
try to make as many things as possible
within its own borders and reduced to an
absolute minimum any reliance on foreign
imports the role of government was to
help local industries by applying huge
tariffs on imported goods and
discouraging foreign manufacturers from
competing with local players a strong
country was one that knew how to provide
for itself and could achieve almost
total independence in trade a goal known
as economic AutoKey the philosophy of
mercantilism reigned supreme as the most
persuasive theory of economics until the
9th of March 1776 the publication date
of possibly the most important book in
the history of the modern world in an
inquiry into the nature and causes of
the wealth of nations the Scottish
philosopher and economist Adam Smith
attempted to dynamite the intellectual
underpinnings of mercantilism Smith
argued that the best way for any country
to grow wealthy was not to try to make
everything by itself for no country
could ever hope to do well in every
sector of an economy Smith observed the
country's naturally had different
strengths in particular areas some were
great at making wine others had talent
in
pottery other still might be experts at
making lace and it was on such strengths
that every country should focus this was
an application at the level of nations
of a theory we can understand well
enough at the level of individual life
if someone has a natural aptitude for
accountancy it makes no sense for them
to spend a considerable part of each day
trying also to make cheese to sew their
own trousers or to learn to play violin
sonatas far better for the accountant
cheesemaker
tailor and violinist to specialise in
the areas in which they have the
greatest advantage and then trade with
others to satisfy their remaining needs
as Smith noted it is the maxim of every
prudent master of a family never to
attempt to make at home what it will
cost him more to make than to buy Smith
emphasized that if Britain could produce
woollen goods more cheaply than Portugal
and if Portugal could produce wine more
cheaply than Britain then it would be
beneficial to both parties to exchange
the product they could make at a lower
cost for the one they could only make at
a higher cost the overall wealth of both
countries would rise as labor and
capital will always be optimally
employed directed to those sectors when
native skill and opportunity was at its
greatest the job of the government was
to recognize sectors where there was a
national advantage assists in the
education of the workforce but otherwise
reduced tariffs as much as possible and
step out of the way with astonishing
speed Smith's theory convinced most of
the economic and political classes of
northwestern Europe in Britain his ideas
were first put to a practical test in
relation to the primary foodstuff of the
nation corn grain prices had for many
years been protected by government
decrees cheaper foreign grain had been
kept out apparently in order to protect
jobs and national wealth but Smith's
ideas now driven forward by his foremost
disciple David Ricardo proposed that all
tariffs on imported grain protectionist
measures known as the Corn Laws were in
fact obstacles to economic growth after
bitter debates in Parliament the laws
were repealed in 1846
the result demonstrated both the
advantages and incidental costs of
Smith's ideas the price of corn dropped
sharply food became cheaper and everyone
especially the working classes had a lot
more spare money to spend on other goods
this in turn grew the overall size of
the British economy so that it
significantly outperformed all of its
European counterparts about and it was a
very big but large swathe of British
agriculture went to the wall cheap
imported corn from Canada and the United
States destroyed farms and ways of life
that had persisted for centuries
Smith's theories were both correct and
depending on where one was standing
plainly agonising an enduring problem
for the undoubtedly very sound arguments
in favour of free trade is that its
human costs have seldom been addressed
with sufficient passion and ingenuity
the cries of the dispossessed have not
been recognized for what they are
threats to the entire stability and
moral dignity of a nation as has only
gradually been realized the benefits of
an open economy can only properly bear
fruit if a series of steps are taken to
mitigate the attendant downsides any
nation committed to free trade must tax
the sectors of the economy which have an
advantage and then use the money to
retrain those in the sectors of the
economy with the gravest disadvantages
in relation to foreign competition
without such redirection of money and
labor a nation will become highly
unstable politically thereby endangering
any progress that free trade has made
secondly governments must enable
everyone in the economy to find their
own natural areas of strength which
means high levels of investment in
education and a raft of measures to
maximize social mobility monopolistic
behavior by the rich in dangers the
integrity of a free trade system just as
much as punitive import tariffs
intellectually free trade has
undoubtedly won the argument when a
Mexican worker can make a car for $8 an
hour
whereas an American one costs fifty
eight dollars an hour it's clearly wise
to allow Mexico to do what it
can do best whatever the effect on
American car workers however defenders
of free trade have been grossly
negligent when it comes to instituting
the political programs necessary to
support the efficient operations of the
system it has forgotten the pain of the
car workers the coal miners and the
steel makers and in democracies there
has been a heavy price to pay for this
neglect in the form of the rise of a new
class of mecan't lists who have
successfully argued that barriers must
again increase that a country should try
to make everything within its own
borders to regain its greatness and that
cheap importers are invariably the
Destroyers of domestic jobs these
arguments make no sense but so long as
the proponents of free trade fail
properly to articulate a program to
remedy free trade operations whole
nations will be seduced by the easy
promises of the mercantilists
and will suffer accordingly until the
distinctive wisdom of Adam Smith can
once more reassert itself
you